Guys, welcome to module four and we're going to talk about the finish work.
We're going to talk about on page SEO and we're using the metaphor or we're using the
example of doing this with physical real estate.
So if we had a house or let's say that we had two houses, exact same square footage,
exact same bedrooms, exact same everything and one of these homes had nice finishes.
One of them had, you know, upgraded tile, upgraded fixtures, maybe it had heated floors,
maybe it had like a sauna inside.
That house, even though it's the same structure, could potentially sell for a lot more.
So though I think it's kind of a funny example because our websites are not that pretty,
I'm just giving you an example because what we do with our on page SEO, we can have two
different websites, one with spectacular on page SEO that can generate way more calls
than the exact same website that looks basically the same, almost identical, that does not
have the on page SEO done correctly.
And therefore the first one would generate almost infinitely more leads.
And why is that for those of you that are still wrapping your head around this?
Because if we do the on page SEO correctly, we're going to rank our website and if we
rank our website, we're going to get organic traffic as long as it converts.
But I know it's going to convert because I'm showing you guys exactly what these websites
need to look like.
Long story short, guys, SEO, there are two different sections or two different parts
to SEO.
There's the on page and then there's the off page.
And we are going to talk about the on page SEO, which is exactly as it sounds, the things
that you do on the page.
So a couple of those things, and I'm just going to mention a few, and then we're going
to have individual sections, individual lessons talking about each one and showing you exactly
how to do each one.
Some of the elements to on page SEO.
Page titles.
And we're going to go into that, but that is what we actually title the page when you
are on your browser and you hover over the tab, what is that thing that pops up?
What is the page title?
Or when you go to Google and you type in concrete near me, what is that title that's underlined?
That's the page title.
We're also going to talk about the descriptions.
What do we put in the description?
How do we get people to click?
How many characters can we do?
We're going to talk about H1s.
We're going to talk about image optimization.
We're going to talk about a lot of different elements of on page optimization.
For some of you that might be junkies with this stuff, we're not going to go into every
little teeny thing, but we're going to talk about the most important things, the things
that have helped us and they have worked again and again and again and again.
These are the things that we do, always keeping in mind that if we do the job correctly with
what we talked about in module one of part one, looking for layups, we can eliminate
competition.
That is why I stress so much that we choose the right city and the right niche because
if the competition is not that great, we don't have to do all this stuff perfect.
We're going to do it as best we can and you're going to get better as you go, as you do this.
We're going to show you step by step exactly what to do in future videos.
Guys, get ready.
Let's figure out how we can master the elements of on page SEO and we'll see you in the next
video.